a Swift and decisive Fall From Grace for
now convicted murderer Alex Murdoch
welcome everyone to Entertainment
Tonight this Blockbuster case has
captivated the nation yes it has the
former South Carolina attorney disgrace
disbarred and his fate now sealed two
consecutive life sentences for the
horrific murders of his wife and son
there are no winners today today's Court
proceedings it was dramatic it almost
played out like a movie you had Alec
Murdock walking in his tan jumpsuit no
more dress shirt and suit as we saw him
for the last six weeks and even Alec
Murdock himself saying I'm innocent I'm
innocent
I would never hurt my wife Maggie and I
would never hurt my son pawpaw I
sentenced you to prison for the rest of
your natural life did you feel like he
was a liar a good liar today's
Revelation it only took the jury about
45 minutes to convict the disbarred
South Carolina lawyer he cried a lot on
the stand he never cried the only bill
was blue snot
America's been obsessed because this
True Crime Story has so many layers
money laundering a hired Hitman
cover-ups and a mysterious double murder
like a John Grisham novel come to life
there are currently four documentaries
streaming about the violent crime
Netflix three-part docu-series has been
in its top 10 all week
how could this happen it's something
that people struggled with How could a
father snap in a way that kills his wife
and youngest son explosive new details
in the story that stunned the country
Primetime shows including Dateline and
48 Hours have also put Alex in the
spotlight with this story anything can
happen
hey Twitter world it's me yours truly
even O.J weighed in I do think this guy
more than likely did it but once again
more than likely to me is tenement to
reasonable doubt we had almost a quarter
million people I think we actually had
more than a quarter million people on
Law and crime watching live and yep the
internet was buzzing today about
adapting the case into a feature film as
for who'd play Alex the speculation
includes Nick Nolte John Goodman Matt
Damon and Alec Baldwin if this doesn't
hit the big screen I don't know why not
someone's missing an opportunity
[Music]